[Music]
in internet justice news Oh submitted by
David looking good people like being a
lot what's going on here so saying it
every time just like a childhood like
rivalry you guys are just like a bunch
of rivalry that we don't we like each
other on sometimes and some on sometimes
I tell him he did a good job at the
wedding and you're like stop me yeah
what is wrong with you stop but I was
like I have to deal with this every week
and I just did I just take it when I was
trying to lose weight she was the most
fun supportive person ever give me an
example
I just put a picture of her [ __ ] ugly
ass face on my walls like you know I
know that he doesn't really think I'm
ugly because he has a crush on gal gadot
or however you say her last name I love
her and people say I look like her
so hey you know what it is you how
people say like enemies are really your
truly our greatest teachers and
motivators in life like maybe you guys
are just like lovely each other up
constantly yeah I need enemies
I think I'll progress in life better
sometimes like somebody that's like
really gets under your skin it's like I
have to work through that to level up I
already know who you got to work with Oh
Cameron when I have those feelings about
people I think about finding a way to go
on vacation with them and go skydiving
and then [ __ ] up their parachute and
kick them out dirty you do that so then
you just waste your own time could be
doing something else like oh he got you
there now you really make me want to do
it [ __ ] you've got no empty promises
mashallah see at the end of your lives
thank each other for like making
yourself better do that now yeah this is
what's gonna be on my deathbed right
well like secretly you'll know it was
like wow use the biggest and new shoes
which helped lead police to a fatal hit
and run to rest how fatal hit-and-run I
read
helped to lead police to a fatal
hit-and-run arrest yes a fatal
hit-and-run capture that dog I know it's
super [ __ ] up especially fatal the
dude died was he like sure I don't know
no he's probably like Oh should I kill
someone photo shoot I'm drunk
mmm these photos were posted on that
subreddit called what is this thing I
love the autists of Internet's in
Washington State Oh US marshal what is
that kind of a bad detective Washington
State Patrol
that's a [ __ ] fat badge dude no
wonder in the movies like if you get
shot and then that bullet just just so
happens they hit that badge and you
[ __ ] survived it always does this was
a photo that was posted to Reddit along
with this this is the bike of where the
Joe that bike got [ __ ] up yeah the
[ __ ] feels like white onion rings so
then the cops are trying to figure out
like what is this thing this is this is
it was left behind by the vehicle what
the wheels look like it's all twisty
you're talking about we're spilling that
food tip yeah so one of the editors
discovered that it belongs to a very
specific vehicle because that person
would change headlights for these
vehicles and so they discovered that it
belonged to a headlamp bezel from a 1988
Chevy Silverado God now the Internet is
know yeah because this person named just
nuts
someone like that solve the crimes like
jizz forever21
solve the biggest crime in the world oh
no my bad Jeff
that's what the detective actually not
just forever21
he described himself as a Maryland state
vehicle inspector so he would inspect
these chestnuts so he knew exactly which
car it wasn't like sure enough they
found the dude oh cool that is a really
cool truck I never thought racing
stripes on a truck would make sense I
feel like a guy named Skeeter drives
that truck
you only has one name not kidding
Skeeter Bob Vegas two first names so
then they tweeted that the thanks to
that redditor they were able to find the
person it's pretty crazy who was the
person I'm going to imma just fill in
the details for you it was Skeeter Bob
this happened in Tennessee and he was
drunk because so then Washington State
yeah I remember the detail okay now it
just changed now it changed to a hipster
did you know how hipsters like those
old-school cars and lame jackass the
spot Jack I don't know what
stereotypical hipster name like he was
trying to come up with the fake name
he's like a P so what is it River North
River North I've heard North from
Washington State he was drinking a
[ __ ] Pat's Blue Ribbon yeah he just
got broken up with his girlfriend all
identified as a man who identifies as a
man who's also a binary binary person
and he was leaving his yurt in the
middle of the night and he crashed and
he thought it was a deer in a scare
and left I think people just panic at
the moment and just like which is no
excuse tonight of oh yeah they just
freaked out literally that up yeah we go
back to what I'm trying to [ __ ] run do
I'm not calling myself in crazy when I
was watching that first that first
episode of that show dude there was two
things that ran through my mind to watch
the show it's like I can only watch one
episode of night cuz it's too intense
yeah I watched the first episode all I
could think of was two things I was like
number one I like this kid is such a
[ __ ] dweeb
right because he doesn't know what the
[ __ ] to do no protocol whatsoever
number two his parents shelter the [ __ ]
out of him so it's their fault you why I
was on Branca yeah so I watched that my
[ __ ] this all can happen to me
everything this can happen to me I'm
like I'm not gonna leave anything
anymore
all I thought about was like that's why
you don't shelter your [ __ ] kids it
was like one night that he finally got
to do something cool and he doesn't know
what to do you know I mean and it just
[ __ ] him all I thought it was dope that
he seduced a lawyer though she kissed
him in jail he became a [ __ ] thug
though he got game after I think if I
was wrongly accused and I was sent to
jail then I would be like [ __ ] it that's
what they believe kingpin all the way
you wouldn't care about loss of your
freedom well I mean it depends on the
crime right like if I'm in there for a
long time I might as well I admit to the
role murder I'm gonna get how would you
be so you turn to it dude I'd get a
boyfriend I think I'll be like the guy
immediately they're like sir you're only
gonna spend like two months here no I
need a boyfriend I'll get a I'll get the
toughest dude there to be my boyfriend
so he could protect me wait it sounds
like you're the boyfriend in that
scenario
no but he's like my bodyguard boyfriend
but I'm still it's like taking a break
over here bottom no no no that's the
only way it's gonna wait why would I
give my butthole like 20 times first
yeah yeah but then it's kind of like how
the wife is really in control the
relationship but then less but she's
really manipulating him from the out
like you know that's the real gangster I
just admit
you're getting the dick of ass but
that's a stepping stone you know what I
mean like he admits it
that's like me okay so I'm gonna climb
up the social status ladder by being
like the boyfriend of the toughest
gangster and then I'm gonna like rule
him and then when the time is right
they're gonna know I'm the real boss and
then I'm gonna murder the toughest guy
in jail and then they're gonna know not
only did I suck this man off and [ __ ]
him I killed him and I'm like the
craziest dude there but here's the thing
you've thought though I'm gonna have so
many cigarettes like in Top Ramen
because if you're with the top dude he's
gonna shower me with so many gifts that
I'm gonna have so much stockpile top
ramen and cigarettes as you were saying
all of this all that picture you doing
was wearing a white jumpsuit and a pink
[ __ ] scarf the entire time the night
of your shoulders called and then even
know the depths of how nasty I will go
to [ __ ] roll we know dude you don't
do it but why do you want to remove it
your legend don't make that bill makes
our job just feel like I just I'll just
I've lose for my time just reading books
working out making myself better that
sounds pretty good
you didn't know that option was there I
don't I have no I have no desire to like
play politics looks like I'm sure your
book workout and just sure would be
boring comparing this it would be but I
wouldn't but it wouldn't be a show yeah
that's like it out then I'd be like man
I love I don't even know the option I
was like I'm in [ __ ] well I better make
it the best thing you're so legible for
parole right yeah anything crazy oh damn
I didn't know that but even still if
you're like behavior and Jill is like if
people like vouch for you like hills do
it's cool yeah somebody we know her
cousin just got out of jail for it's
like 20 years he was in prison and he
came out and then oh you want you know
talk to talk to your mom's cool give him
a [ __ ] iPhone with FaceTime he was
like I use my blown
20 [ __ ] years do the like the world
has changed dramatically doesn't know
what the [ __ ] is going there's some
people that like sneaking iPhones into
jail yes TK what's his name that
represent get three iPhones in jail you
like FaceTime it's the the security guys
I mean yeah you pay much but why don't
you miss your friends after all those
memories that you make work for ten
years in jail and then you got to leave
that other jail I don't even want
FaceTime cuz I don't want to know how to
dope it is outside I want to be there
and present with the [ __ ] because if I
know there's something better out there
it makes me feel y'all just read books
not just someone's face I mean be
present we're trying to hang out yeah I
just
[Music]